[Aplausos]
soy música y antropóloga como
antropóloga me especialicé en un grupo
africano los bosquimanos que viven en el
desierto del kalahari botsuana áfrica
si a los bosquimanos les interesará la
antropología cosa que no es y un antro y
un antropólogo bosque mano viniera a
conocer nuestra cultura una de las cosas
que más le llamaría la atención es que
poco hacer musical que tenemos en la
vida cotidiana
cuando yo empecé a trabajar con ellos
con los tweets y los caracteres de
botsuana de la reserva central lo que
más me sorprendió es la música que había
absolutamente en todas sus
manifestaciones cotidianas
los bosquimanos fueron los habitantes
originarios de toda la región sur de
áfrica después fueron arrinconados desde
el continente y desde abajo desde el
agua también hasta finalmente estar
concentrados en la reserva central del
kalahari
qué pasaba con este grupo yo veía
estaban tristes cantaban estaban
contentos bailaban y cantaban el médico
necesita que las mujeres canten y
golpeen sus palmas para ayudarlo a
conectarse con los espíritus se canta y
se festeja el nacimiento de una nueva
mujer cantando alrededor de la casa de
esa mujer del canto los chicos los
chicos usan su cuerpo para ser ritmos
hay rondas con canciones todos los
bosquimanos cantan y bailan
porque porque la música es de todos no
hay especialistas no hay uno que diga
bueno yo hago esto no todos como
aprenden los bosquimanos su cultura
los chicos eso lo vi muchísimo cantan
bailan hacen
cuentan todo lo que hacen los adultos
los chicos lo viven y así es que como
los adultos hacen mucha música
los chicos nacen con esa música cuando
volvía de estas expediciones que hice
durante mucho tiempo me llamaba mucho la
atención en nuestra cultura como no
estaba no estaba yo diría como esa
música que viene con nosotros
había un cierto permiso cuando pero que
cuando ustedes levantan un bebé y les
dice cantar
[Música]
hay algo que conecta con el movimiento y
con el canto y es muy importante ese
momento porque por los chicos es la
música la primera música que escuchan
fuera de la panza ya que dentro de la
pasa también la escuchan
y son arroyos son arroyos que son que
vienen de otras infancias arroyos que
vienen de otros países de donde vienen
nuestros padres o arroyos que no tienen
que ver no tienen que estar canciones de
cuna por ejemplo un sobrino mío arrulla
a su bebé con una murga uruguaya porque
él es uruguayo lo que vale es ese canto
que nosotros queremos compartir ahí
y entonces yo dije que pasó tiene que
ver con los medios de comunicación
masivos que en los últimos años es como
si nos hubiera sacado el azar musical y
somos muy buenos escuchas tenemos muy
buenos aparatos y la audición también es
maravillosa porque lo oído también lo
tenemos y con el oído escuchamos nos
conectamos la naturaleza música que nos
conmueve de boca eso es maravilloso pero
yo tuve el tiempo digo ese hacer musical
que da energía y que da alegría
los bosquimanos un pueblo una cultura
que tiene 20 mil años que nos lleva a
los orígenes de la humanidad y es como
si esa música de la panza ellos la
trasladaron a su vida cotidiana y se
mueven con ella como si estuviera allí
desde siempre
porque la música es de todos porque nos
pertenece porque así como la tenemos
caminamos brincamos tenemos la voz
tenemos el cuerpo
yo tengo ritmo yo también
yo tengo ritmo yo tengo ritmo yo también
yo también estoy un poquitito resfriado
estoy un poquitito resfriado estoy un
poquito resfriado hachís
hachís
yo no sé dónde estará yo no sé quiero
bailar cha cha cha quiero bailar quiero
bailar
cha cha cha
dónde estará
estoy un poquitito resfriado yo tengo
ritmo
tenemos esta s
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y creo que si nosotros nos remontamos
bastantes años atrás cuando todavía todo
lo que tiene que ver con los medios
masivos de comunicación no nos había
invadido para bien y para mal para mal
porque ya le voy a contar pero en
realidad la música si nosotros queríamos
que haya música le teníamos que hacer
porque no había radio no habían aparatos
entonces era muy común eso de ver de
juntarse por ejemplo en un patio y sacar
un violín una guitarra o en los campos
de algodón de los negros en estados
unidos que cantaban esos swing los
serbios
kamynin forus carry mío
son los serbios
y tantos colectivos donde ellos cantaba
uno y contestaban todos también los
cantos de los alpinos subiendo a las
montañas los vascos que hoy en día se
siguen juntando a cocinar y a cantar
y otra cosa que a mí me gusta mucho son
en españa las mujeres se juntaban para
hacer el pan
hacían el pan en su mesa
y mientras el pan se estaba cocinando
que hacían y hacia el ritmo
[Aplausos]
ayer en las paradas
por la calle de san juan
engañando a los chiquillos cuatro perros
mal un pan dime para verte para
habilitar cómo va el trato
la harina va subiendo y el pan barato
y así seguíamos el distinto
en las grandes ciudades tenemos
manifestaciones musicales que son
importantes colectivas por ejemplo las
manifestaciones políticas donde se canta
en las canchas de fútbol donde se canta
pero durante las dos horas del partido
las murgas las las procesiones
religiosas tenemos mucho de eso que está
bárbaro pero lo tenemos en determinados
contextos y momentos y yo todo el tiempo
habló de la música esa de todos los días
de cantar bien a mí me pasó el otro día
yo donde más escucho músicas en el auto
entonces estaba escuchando algo y me dio
una energía y entonces empecé a golpear
el volante cantaba yo creo que si
alguien me venía de si está loca pero
eso a mí me gusta mucho cuando veo que
de golpe pasa un chico por la puerta de
mi casa con
audi auriculares iba cantando con su con
su autor favorito a los gritos o pasan
silbando o bailas eso es nuestro eso es
nuestro y a mí lo que me da más pena de
eso es que si no lo usamos nos perdemos
esa alegría que da esa alegría y esa
energía que da la música
yo verdaderamente creo que no hay por
suerte una música universal
tenemos músicas muy diversas muy lindas
de distintos países de distintas
regiones y esos maravillosos
la diversidad y la riqueza de cada
música pero yo sí creo que hay una
necesidad universal de cada uno de
nosotros para que usemos nuestra música
bien que de golpe uno dice no a mi
misión el coro que no cante listo ya
está bastante más no no es lo mío
había pasado de estar en reuniones
sociales la gente sabía que yo me
dedicaba a la música entonces se hace un
canto que van a cantar todos me miran
como pidiéndome permiso no la música no
es de los profesionales valga la
redundancia que es maravilloso tener
profesionales cuando uno quiere
disfrutar y escuchar lo que está pasando
pero yo hablo de esa otra música de esa
música que es nuestra y me pasó cuando
me dijeron de esta charla yo quería
hablar de esto que inventé una canción
en mente una canción para compartir con
ustedes para compartir la alegría de la
música y dice así
un paraguas y toba
que si va a washington va
y qué tomba
un para
un paraguas y tumba
a un paraguas y tan baja
para brasil
un paraguas y tumba
gracias
un chihuahua sí tomba
un tomba
un parásito más
oye que un parásito en ba
muñecas y bagua si tomba
hoy el que tumba
la tumba tumba papá
a esta música que son todas palabras que
en realidad no quieren decir nada por
eso no me acordaba del principio
pero en realidad
[Aplausos]
[Música]
lo que de verdad quería era cantar algo
todos juntos es compartir esta alegría
este momento que es cantar todos juntos
así que bueno anímense a cantar a bailar
y abrir la puerta para ir a jugar